hey through and I am here at BuzzFeed to
answer your burning questions now you've
got to know there is anointment for that
we'll just get that out of the way now
would you ever want to do a reboot of
drag you or create another drag based
reality series trust me
we have cut this potato so many
different ways we have french fried it
we have auger Otten dit we have eaten it
raw and we are continuing to find new
ways to chop this potato up this
drag-race potato and serve it up in many
different ways for you in fact we're
about to start doing something new with
the potato I think you're gonna like a
lot so yes the answer is yes yes and yes
and Bon Appetit
do you have to be a drag queen or gate
to call you mother no I won't answer you
but you could call me whatever you want
is there anything anyone you would be
nervous to interview on your new talk
show I'm glad you mentioned my new talk
show nervous to interview anyone
probably not I've been around for a
while whenever I go onstage I think ok
rue you're going into Mama's living room
I would perform for my mother in the
living room I could do no wrong there
she would love whatever I did as long as
I showed up and did it so I've kept that
philosophy my whole life so I don't get
nervous for that stuff what makes me
nervous probably being in a room with a
lot of people and not being in charge
with make me nervous
I'm actually an introvert masquerading
as an extrovert how am i doing on
average how long does it take you to get
into drag three hundred years do you
have any wild or surprising stories from
the early years of the pride movement
yes and yes and probably none that I
could tell here I will say that my first
gay pride parade was 1982 in Atlanta
Georgia there were probably only 75
people there was a very tiny affair just
right after World War Two that's a joke
can you tell us how your cattitude
collaboration with Miley Cyrus came to
be she asked me she said
where you have to turn the the album or
the EP in on Monday so you have tomorrow
to record your bits okay I did it and
now it's out do you have a favorite meme
of yourself that has come from drag race
I don't have a favorite one the ones
where I look gorgeous
those are my favorite ones what club in
New York was your favorite to perform at
and wide I like the pyramid Club I think
it still may be their pyramid Club is
the pyramid Club so they're on Avenue a
between 6 & 7
it was like our just literally like a
club where all of us Outsiders would
come and meet up I mean like in the
afternoon at a bar it's the only bar
I've ever really been at in the
afternoon now I was there in 1984 and I
was there until I got famous got famous
in 1992 so when I moved up here in 80
for the first time because the city spit
me out and sent me back home to Atlanta
after about six months but in in 84 when
I moved up here I was sleeping on
people's couches sleeping in the park
and on the piers so I would keep my
belongings in the basement of the
pyramid Club and it was safe there I
couldn't sleep there but I could keep my
stuff there and the pyramid was magical
I used to go go dance on the bar at the
pyramid Club and make a lot of money and
I had this angle to get a lot of money
from the people because I would talk to
them and I was like I was annoying you
got some money for me I could get a lot
of money dancing on the bar at the
pyramid club and you know everybody was
there
this is 1984 everybody was there uptown
downtown black white gay straight
everybody you know I remember coming
down the spiral staircase from the stage
and I came my sweating and some outfits
and crazy outfit and down there in our
dressing room was Madonna holding court
but the pyramid Club the best and they
did them all back in those days you
could go and party
at six clubs a night six clubs a night
seven nights a week and guess what I did
I did exactly that you're an inspiration
blah blah blah I think I'm gonna pass
that one up
that was funny you guys can laugh you
know rotten
do you ever replay a rewatch a lip-sync
before making a final decision no it's
very obvious when you see it the first
time if you could still one look from
any Queen on drag race what look would
you still not I I have my own and
they're more fabulous than anybody's
honestly I'm think for real at the same
time as big tongue-in-cheek yeah my
looks are better than anyone's have you
stopped doing drag outside of drag race
will we ever see you in drag on the talk
show first of all when I do drag I'm
getting paid a lot I don't do it for
free if you want to see me in drag I'm
doing this one show for like 11 years in
drag you can always see me in dress I
mean what more do you want from me
people but I never say never about the
drag on the talk show I did a talk show
about 300 years ago on vh1 where I seen
direct all the time and you could
probably see that on yeah hi roux in
snatch game who would you be LaToya
Jackson I wouldn't do it very well
um and she's a friend of mine and I
would lose I'm sure can you give us any
hints about special segments or games
from the new talk show the only hint
I'll give you as it's really fun I was
born to do a talk show I grew up
watching television I used to practice
having my own talk show in Mama's living
room you know with the couch and my
reluctant sister would be my only guest
this show the talk show is me being of
service me being a mentor to not only
young people but people who find the
21st century tough life is tough and
there's no way around that but you can
arm yourself with knowledge nothing's
new Under the Sun and the future belongs
to those who can remember the
lucky for you I remember the best mama
[Music]
hey guys you can watch my new talk-show
route Paul on Fox television stations
starting June 10th check your local
listings
thanks BuzzFeed
[Music]